hey guys what's up I'm Alana and welcome
to my channel and today we are doing a
new thing that I'm kind of excited about
this is going to be an anonymous Q&A boy
hitting 75,000 subscribers thank you
guys so much so this is gonna include
all the questions that I was asked
except for ones that I haven't asked for
or ones that I have really boring
ancestors so first question is how did
you meet max and pepper Scoville by any
chance do you mean this purpose Scoville
hey little buddy
I don't know how I met max we've been
friends for a long time and I kind of
suspect that maybe he was the person who
asked me this question but as for
peppa's I'm currently living with Max
and his lovely girlfriend Jim so you
know there's a doggie here okay first
other question anonymous said was things
someone has said to you on the internet
I don't know I tried to dwell on that
kind of stuff but because that fresh in
my memory let's just take some stuff
that people said yesterday those kind of
mean some guy said he hates me because I
am a baboon in real life not sure what
that means but I think that he was
trying to say that I'm ugly and then
another guy said something along the
lines of y'all it's so hot that it's
your fault that people are sexist and go
on the internet purpose because people
on the Internet are really mean what's
next for you you're a huge inspiration
to me and I hope you keep getting all
the success you deserve firstly thank
you that's what's next for me that's
something that I do have yet to announce
and I'm really really excited about but
I can't tell you guys about just yet I'm
also going to be working on a
documentary with the ABC and I got a
lead role acting in a TV show so there's
a lot of really cool stuff going on in
my life right now and thank you for
being supportive it's awesome some
people aren't quite as supported so
thank you what I got bubbles for right
now I was really excited about the idea
of the press conference and it being
announced there and me crying a thousand
tears because I was there but now that's
not going to happen
I'm positive no shirt gameplay at the e3
press conference but it's not going to
have the effect on me that
the announcement would have but after
like three years of doing the games
journalism's hype doesn't affect me as
much as it used to so after the
confirmation of fallout 4 I don't have a
much higher plug I mean I'm excited but
I'm gonna hyped the thing that I'm most
hyped for and especially hurry 3 because
I booked it into and I'm so excited is
actually ukelele the next question is
are you gay you walk and talk and act
gay and dress gay no hate you're saying
if I do all those things that I must be
a there's a puppy next to me right now
how loudly can you both know kinda left
up do you want me that's how I pull all
the other gays if you can remake any
game using wooden advancements what game
would you like to see remade probably
jet force Gemini it's a fantastic game
in so many ways but it's kind of
unplayable now because it's on those
crappy Nintendo 64 controls what was
your favorite plushie as a kid um I had
this like glowing one it was like this
thing with like a head and then its body
was kind of like an oval and it was like
wearing a nightgown or something it had
like a little wizard hat kind of like
link and then its face which is just
like giant plastic bit that you could
put a light in so it act like a
nightlight if you wanted it to I don't
have I've used it for that but I
remember it now it didn't have a nose I
had these huge eyes and this smile it
was just kind of like but for some
reason I loved it I also had a pretty
big collection of my little party toys
and of a little like miniature cause
what's the video game that you like that
no one else likes I feel like that's
impossible but a game that I like that
most people generally don't is goats
will be watching
why did you scream innate against robots
question from a live human person you
wrote this didn't you it wasn't real
puzzler all as you I don't know what
this means did I do something against
the robot people yes let's go with the -
my answer is yes what do you actually
want in a guy please answer but that's a
very easy one what I want in a guy
is for cute little legs and a really
cute little puppy face what I wanted to
guys puppy if you could change one thing
about awhile to make it more interesting
you're omnipotent so anything is
possible what would you change
it's a really tough question to make it
more interesting not to make it better I
guess that I would make it so there are
no genders or races and then see what
people ended up choosing to discriminate
against would you ever like to try
something as a sport I have done
something kind of as a sport not
competitively but I have surfed I lived
in Australia man come on how many times
people have asked you for marriage about
tree fiddy anyway in the wall that you'd
really like to visit you haven't yet
everywhere everywhere in the world ever
all of the places how do you feel about
Caitlyn Jenner coming out as a trans
woman I guess I think it's great that
someone who is really prolific has come
out as trans so it'll educate a lot more
people about what that means and why
it's important do you believe in aliens
hell yes and you don't believe in aliens
you are wrong and you kind of make me
angry I don't really arrogant when
humans don't believe in aliens like you
really think that were the only things
alive here come on man
what singular food or drink item do you
miss most of Australia that you are
unable to obtain in the US of a sausage
rolls dude
sausage rolls oh my god I miss them so
much if you could get a million dollars
but all you have to do is lift the
entire bottom of a homeless peasants
foot would you do it why slash why not
hell yes I would do that because I
million dollars it's just a foot you can
like get your teeth cleaned yes
what so that is it from myself and
pepper Scoville today cutie is oh my god
thank you guys for watching I will see
y'all next time